everybody with eyes
saw that we were making clothes that was
around tampa they saw it
so the pimps started to come
in the 70s the 80s the 90s they started
to come we're making clothes for them
in this area in this area
the pimps so we're making clothes for
them
well i don't know about pimps i i never
met a pimp before this but
i got an education it was beautiful
meaning
these are guys doing what my grandmother
was doing
she's trying to survive they're trying
to survive
so the story was
i'm making clothes for a guy named joe
i call him pimp joe we're making lots of
clothes
and it's all good when
joe brings someone to the shop
another pimp
he says as he introduces that person to
michael he says
he's all right what he's saying is he's
all right with what we're doing
he's all right with our skin color he's
all right with
whatever he's not making any judgment
he's making clothes is what he's doing
you want clothes he's your guy but he's
not unhappy
about your shoe size he doesn't care
what kind of shoes you have he doesn't
care what kind of haircut you have
he just makes clothes end a story
and in the process joe tells me
he picked cotton in georgia
i think it's georgia could be carolina
but he picked cotton
and when he was 19 he went to new
orleans
a prostitute saw him and says come on
i'm going to teach you how to be a pimp
you're going to be my pimp what exactly
what
exactly what meaning she knew the game
she knew this guy looked the part and
could act the part
it taught him how to be a pimp that he
comes with the cadillac el dorado and
all that stuff
anyway so we're making clothes for him
we're friends we're we're laughing we're
having fun
now i don't see joe for a few years i
don't think anything of it because they
move around
and they go up north they do this that
whatever i don't see joe
now a car pulls up to our shop behind
our house
on bayshore boulevard south saint south
tampa
two guys get out with suits i'm just
telling you nobody
ever came to that shop with a suit on
what are you talking
dude you know what are you doing with
the suit
it's just there's no reason it's not
that it's against the law there's just
not a reason
you know these are music people these
are wrestlers
suits no so they come in
he said hi we're with the fbi
i said oh let me see the thing let me
see the
sticker and the the badge and all that i
never saw this meaning
here's mike mike's not doing anything
to break the law not because he agrees
with the lord disagrees with the law
or anything or that he wants to break
the law
he's just into peace of mind he doesn't
want to be worried
they're going to come and arrest me
because i was speeding over
here or they think i robbed a bank or
they
you think i'm this or that that make no
difference i don't care
i did nothing you know you're gonna you
want to listen to all my phone
conversations
and see all whatever wrote on the
computer
you'll die of boredom and the story you
know that's i'm
warning you so so they come in i get
them to show me the badges oh this was
so cool
i wish i had pictures but i don't so
they show me
they say do you know joe lee sanders
i said no they take out the mug book
big fat mug book and they open and going
going you know we're on page 20 or
whatever
i said well yeah it's joe pimp joe i
know him
when did you see him last i said i don't
know i'm really bad on time but maybe a
year and a half maybe two years i don't
know
why he was stealing mail
he went to jail for stealing men they're
looking for him again for something i
don't know for the same thing i don't
even know what
they leave now another year goes back
by maybe two i mean again i got no idea
on time
now joe comes i said joe what's
happening
the fbi came here and all that it was
great i mean i got to see the badge and
everything
and he says he said it was a white boy
crime they taught me
white boys taught me how to do steal
mail on the beginning of the month
for some kind of thing you know people
get checks in the mail
and that you you just sign them and you
cash them and whatever i mean i have no
idea what i'm talking about but i mean
that's what he said something like you
get
some kind of checks at the end of the
month or the beginning of the month
and he goes to jail for this thing um
but all i'm saying to you is that
this is just a regular guy trying to
survive meaning that's why he's doing
this
right i'm not saying anything about
legal illegal
and
what it taught me was he's no different
than jimmy
he's no different than macho man
everyone's doing whatever they do
as best as they can whatever their
destiny is however the thing works out
and it's nothing to criticize him about
and it's nothing to say it's wonderful
about
it's nothing it's just this is joe this
is jimmy this is macho man this is
miss elizabeth this is these are just
people
to you they're all people to you they're
all people that walked in your shop that
you
wanted to create they wanted you to
create something for you yeah i mean and
above my shop
where we made the clothes is an
apartment so it's rented to a couple
that we know
the lady is a singer the man
is con is her manager and is connected
with
all the r b groups he knows about this
he brings two guys with him
and he just shows them this is what mike
is doing meaning these people aren't
interested in these kind of clothes
but he brings them in the shop and the
radio's on
and whatever's on the radio they can
sing harmony with
whatever i don't care what it is they
can sing harmony with it
this fast as it's going by they can sing
who is it it's two of the pips gladys
knight in the pips
rainy day rainy night in georgia this is
them
exactly oh wow meaning i'm going wow
these guys can really sing this is a
wild thing that
i mean and i know nothing about it i'm
not a musician i don't
know about that part of it but i know
that these guys were there in the happy
place
with singing background music and these
were the pips
you know meaning exactly exactly
but i think the other thing about you
saying about all the clothes for jimmy
or macho man is that i see him so much
on the internet and on movies and things
and
album covers that it just it's just a
part of life it's just
you know it's something that you did
exactly something that uh exactly i
think i found it so interesting that
how you were able just to treat it like
a job just to treat it as
i almost didn't have time for and that
was the destiny to show me
that these are standard issue human
beings everyone
right everyone don't judge anybody
be kind to all of them be a human being
you know this is you know that's why joe
is saying
he's all right you know he's saying that
we're
mean nothing
you